you know a lot of people were saying
that when jener came on the show I
should have just gone at him way heavier
and they were like Why didn't it pop off
and I was like I was trying to prevent
it from getting into that heated debate
well and there were there were a few
points where we talked about George
Floyd and ammed Arbury where jent got
really heated and I I pulled away from
it trying to keep things down Patrick
bed David the way he went after Anthony
Weiner I mean Ron had to know that pbd
is not going to let him walk away from
the high heel scandal in this way I got
to be honest if Ron came here I would
not drag I would have not I would not
have done that you wouldn't have had a a
box of famo shoes like like it was funny
it's a it's a clip obviously his team
had planned it even the way he's like
phrasing that like I'm sure heard about
this thing like you know this Scandal
about your shoes or whatever like patc
Davis knew what he was doing he knew he
was going to do it with the second you
know he got SST it's a different style
of show it's not the way you operate no
one who comes on the show will ever be
ambushed like that